fine let's move on what's something
positive that happened oh no i'll tell
you another thing i'll tell you another
negative thing that happened sunday
sorry i'll tell you nothing i'll tell
you nothing i think thanks what happened
okay so this is what happened okay
so i was playing destiny with my new
fire team this weekend okay we're doing
the raid on hard mode okay
and so we're now
i have one more level to finish it on
hard mode so we're at the last level
okay
it's hard to get six guys together that
are that good that can finish it we
finally got it monday
before like because at two o'clock it
resets so i had to finish it
before that
okay look at that kaleila she's gonna
we're gonna get a we're gonna have a big
fight that night
we're gonna fight last night
oh did we yeah
y'all let me in the car but anyway um
so i'm playing and she goes we gotta
take the dog to the vet because the dog
has a little belly thing what is it
her she might our dog recently got
spayed and her cert her sutures her
stitches burst open
which is sort of a medical emergency
medical emergency okay
so she goes we got to go to i go i know
but we got
it resets i have to do it now it's never
going to happen again
it's to get this far
we got i got you know
can you take her
no i had to go
and we went and then we're going to find
the club you said first you said how
about we wait until tomorrow i'm like
okay well i see how you would treat a
child now that's not the same it's like
everything
this is what i don't like about you you
say you're a sober man but you're not a
sober man because of the way that you
treat people around you are circling
this a new addiction of yours you
replace one addiction with another and
you think that all of a sudden you're
absolved from all kinds of bad behavior
but you treat people around you like
[ __ ] and i'm gonna call you out for it
yesterday we needed you as a family the
dog's belly ruptured it eviscerated and
i needed you to come with me oh yeah
yeah gilbert i'm not talking to you baby
and you had been playing six hours of
video games up until that point so for
me to say hey can i take you away for 30
minutes to go down the street to the vet
you
it is your responsibility
to say yes i'm sorry
but in the meantime you make me walk on
eggshells and treat me like [ __ ] and you
you [ __ ] you you you cry and you
whine and you talk about how how
the world is ending because you have to
leave your 17 year old friends in a
video game
do those do their parents even know
they're playing with a 45 year old man
who sucked dick before
that's true
that's all true
i'm going to call danny i'm going to
call danny garcia's parents i'm going to
call that british kid's parents
i'm going to be like hey do you know
that every day first of all baby danny
garcia is listening right now and he's a
danny
you're a great desi player you're a
great destiny player and you're in your
um english friend
trickle is very talented trickle trick
trick the held is trickle 19. yeah okay
is that real is that i don't know i
don't know i don't i've never met him
okay but i want to say this i'm going to
call their parents okay i'm going to say
this when i did suck the dicks
just danny danny listen and trickle and
the other guys all right omi okay
i was a kid too
so as a 45 year old man i didn't a 17
year old kid
as when i was a four i'm 45 now i
haven't sucked
young dick i was young three decades
long time ago exactly thank you gilbert
for defending me i was young so i
i sucked you know me when i got drunk or
whatever my cousin whatever whatever
everyone knows everyone knows okay but i
did as an adult i haven't so don't think
that i'm gonna first of all you live in
england i'm gonna fly over there to suck
your day it's so expensive it's very
expensive hold it past him no
kleila if these guys call me tomorrow
and they go listen they go we listen to
the podcast and hey dude i'm sorry i bet
you're you know we think you're funny
good comic or whatever but we our
parents don't want because you suck you
can't play with us
i'm gonna be like i'm gonna be like lyla
we have a [ __ ] problem i'm gonna make
sure that happens
i'm gonna look for trump trinkle's real
name is that his name trinkle
trickle
i know danny garcia
yeah you're good to danny
and every if you're in l.a you come
invited in my house
okay
but like to play video yeah play video
games
i don't suck dick
he just made
[Laughter]
but you know i came home and i um needed
to catch up
on the destiny
because everyone did
i played the whole time i was gone
and now i'm behind
and i played yesterday but i got in
trouble
why'd you get in trouble kalyala
um let's see he comes through the door
drops his suitcase gets a hog and doss
yeah ice cream before he laughs doesn't
finish the haagen-dazs makes it makes it
melt on the floor
[Laughter]
yeah in a span of three minutes turns
our home into an absolute just like
crime scene yeah that watches the dog
you know piss in front of him on the
floor
and then proceeds to scream for 10 hours
straight at the tv i mean tell me
what what type of person i would have to
be
to not at least be
to be even you know annoyed
and
i didn't
that i was trying to communicate to him
and then he goes oh hey i'm going to
dinner with eric at 7 30. mind you i've
been sick all weekend didn't offer me no
food okay
no meds then offer me a kiss or a hug
shut the [ __ ] up with your own man oh
you didn't kiss you look at me right now
wait wait wait stop right now right now
no it's not right here babe i'm sorry i
apologize but i wanna look at me right
now if you ever give me a [ __ ] o like
that again my friend all right you have
another thing coming which is i don't
know
oh god it's a mystery it's a mystery
it's a mystery one all right so i want
you to [ __ ] apologize gilbert i'm
sorry that i said oh when you didn't
kiss your girlfriend when you got home
you're welcome
and i forgive you go ahead baby
um
i mean it's the same argument we always
have i have a pretty high threshold for
video
she's the best girlfriend in the world i
don't tell him when to stop i don't give
him like a treat baby but yesterday i
was sick and i just needed a little bit
of like hi kalylah i know you exist and
you're sick and you're dying on a bed i
needed just just an ounce of it
that's it and i was trying to
communicate that to him and all he said
to me was i'm after playing 10 hours he
says i don't want to talk about it i'm
too tired i need a nap and then he goes
and
doesn't talk to me okay and then yeah
yeah and um and then um
he wakes up he goes to dinner and then
at dinner he realizes what no he had
done stop stop stop stop stop stop okay
number one okay i want you to apologize
what for what
i want you to apologize right now kalila
for what just to do it just
he always makes me do this yeah yeah
just to do it you say i am so sorry you
know what bobby i really am sorry that
you have just zero capacity
i heard sorry and that's all i need to
do
but just the thought that he just you
know i mean did this crazy story about
it's funny story yeah you know i mean
but it's like it makes me seem
disgusting you are disgusting
there's no other better word to describe
you than disgusting you are that
i am what i totally get white
what do you mean
you're you're a disgusting
creature
whoa
you are
as am i
that's why this works together that's
what my rebellion exists
but disgusting in what way
i mean
i don't think that you getting a
prostitute is disgusting i just think
that
and what i mean disgusting not in a
negative way it's more like
you do [ __ ]
that the average person wouldn't
get into for example give me an example
you know 69 with we know family members
okay stop
stop okay
yes
i did 69 with a family member
and it happened to him be a man
a boy
but
that was a k i was a kid yeah and and is
it because i talk about it that i'm
discussing or i actually did that
i mean gosh i don't you because a lot of
kids have done weird things that they
would never talk about yeah like i don't
george i don't know what he's done yeah
but i know he's done some [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ]
in his personal life yes you have yeah
you did jordan yeah you did george but
overall you are just disgusting like
even with hygiene though let's keep it
real okay all right that's this is about
being real yeah and this is about me on
honestly
looking myself in the mirror and going
okay let's let's find out who i really
am all right so tell me all you need to
do is take this camera and then see your
side of the bed
what's on your side of the bed sunflower
seeds i love them three-year-old banana
peels delicious
smoothies he has just let dry out
fermenting fermenting
i mean just fish guts like
fish that's wrong you did that as a joke
and that's wrong
there's never been fish that's on the
side of my bed
all right oh go inside this car actually
it's straight up smells like horse
manure and i can't figure out why
because i ride horses i i take i took
his car to get washed i'd interior an
exterior and right after that it still
smells like
[ __ ] animal manure and i can't figure
out why
and it's because it's just years and
years and years of like fermenting
whatever in there maybe i'm you're right
i don't know i don't know how to change
that about myself
hygiene wise yeah just i'm just a dirty
dirty person
and i've always have been and it's like
i've
i've gotten by this far for being you
know you know what you don't have though
body odor thank you i was gonna say and
that's a fact
and that's real have you told everybody
about your new portable xbox oh i saw a
picture you've seen it
have you been able to use it yet on the
road wow it's called a vanguard black
edition
and i've never seen anybody so happy to
open up a package in his life
this thing is spiffy it's it comes in it
looks like a small little um um
it's like carry-on suitcase no it's like
there's tools or something that should
be in it's hard cased
and you you open it up there's a screen
inside it and your xbox slides in there
and the sound is amazing
the [ __ ] graphics are amazing and you
could just take it anywhere
and um you can play so
what were your thoughts when you saw it
um extreme um sadness oh why sorrow
um
actually no i'm okay with it because i
mean he's he's gonna use it when he's on
the road
yeah and he's already um i'm fine with
that he can scream all he wants in his
in the privacy of this hotel room in a
different city i'm okay with it but what
he does is this is what i don't
understand actually
first i thought that i was okay with it
and then he has this new thing where
he'll sit next to me while i'm trying to
sleep in bed
and he thinks he's killing two birds
with one stone because he's screaming on
the xbox but then he's like do you like
that i'm next to you sweetie i like that
so he thinks he's spending time with me
and at the same time playing xbox and i
don't like the screaming that's what i
don't like i don't care that he plays
well they're going to really we're going
to do a raid tonight babe oh fantastic i
won't be around for that when i'm not i
promise i'm on screen
i know no i promise you i won't scream
have you ever not screamed during a raid
no tonight i scream [ __ ] no i won't
i promise you i won't how about this
every time i scream i'll give you a
hundred dollars
i don't want your money wow every time i
scream i give you a 30 minute
every time he screams he gives me a
hundred dollars
[Laughter]
yeah
i think that you know if i were crazy
yeah this should be should we take a
pause and wait for the dog to stop
barking
power through let's power through or
should we just power this part of it
guys the ambiance of the tiger belly
yeah sorry guys we have a four month old
puppy and she just won't iconic how is
that going by the way you guys
love it love hate middle i mean now we
love it i mean i love the dog but it
she's
completely insane it's hard work any
puppy is hard work though they just want
to eat everything they're very
indiscriminate about what they want to
eat if it's your hands feet ears they
don't give a [ __ ]
or last night like i she goes go pee i
brought her downstairs
she walked around for a couple of
minutes she doesn't have to pee i bring
her upstairs she goes on the bed and she
pees all over the bed
wow and then who do you think i get mad
at she gets mad at the dog i don't get
mad at the dog i get mad at me you get
mad at the dog because getting mad at me
is [ __ ] absurd well it's crazy it's
useless because it goes one ear out the
other no because no let's okay um okay i
didn't want to get into it but i will uh
i it's 9 30 uh-huh uh-huh i have a show
at 10 o'clock at the comedy store and it
takes about 15 minutes to get there
okay
and the adam eager the the um guy that
books the comedy store said listen can
ever all the comics show up 15 minutes
before their spot because we go crazy
when
comics aren't around and you guys show
up a minute before your spot freaks them
out it freaks them out and it's i i get
it
so i was gonna leave at 9 30 but she's
like go peer downstairs because it takes
two minutes
but i brought her down there two minutes
she walked around she didn't pee
now it's like 9 32 9 33
i go she doesn't have to pee i brought
her back upstairs and she peed on the
bed but i was gone by that point okay
but
what i need you to have more of is just
common sense you know that she's not
potty trained completely so what we've
been doing is keeping her in the crate
because she doesn't pour pee in the
crate because that's where she sleeps
and you know that she'll hold her
bladder however long she needs but no
you let her out in the house she jumps
on the bed and she pees i know but it
could have been i just it
wasn't as easy as putting your eyes and
you know that but you're too lazy to do
it no
the easiest thing is for you to take her
down
but i take her down 90 minutes i
understand i understand that sweetie but
i'm just saying in that specific
situation it's every specific situation
i should take her down bobby that's the
thing about this
this relationship it's always like 99
of all the work has to be on my
shoulders
when you started it i know anyway it's
my fault anyways let the dog peed on the
bed and i apologize
thank you
love you know in any court i would have
won but in what court
any court but
the reason why you have a situation
in a situation i'm at fault and i'm
sorry and i'm saying sorry to everyone
that's listening that i [ __ ] up you
know i mean i should have been late to
the comedy store
i should have stayed down there as long
as it took for the dog to pee
and that's my fault and my bed i
apologize give me a kiss baby
that's my bad okay
because we live in a crazy world
where i'm wrong in that situation in
that specific situation yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah uh claudia look at her eyes
look at her before hilarious
but like i just yell and i act maniacal
but they know they know it's an act i'm
not i mean yeah i'm a good person guys
believe me i mean look at your eyes you
guys are [ __ ] like you guys are
[ __ ] um crucifying me right now
i just said i was in awe of you you
broke my [ __ ] xbox you [ __ ]
yeah oh hell no
well i've never seen anybody get off the
couch so fast to go to best buy and when
his xbox broke yesterday he's like baby
i'm out of here where are my car keys
also so quickly i love how you made
george think that he broke her xbox he
didn't break your ass we don't know
okay
stop okay
we don't know what
happened is that george that's true
that's 100 true i know what happened you
still no hot cocoa all over it all right
here's what it is i'm going to tell
everyone what happened okay
yesterday was it yesterday yeah okay
yesterday george comes over and goes i'm
going to set up your twitch
right
so my xbox is working fine that night
before completely fine
and then all of a sudden he puts the
twitter downloads to twitch i turn the
machine back on it just keeps turning
off and then eventually it just doesn't
work anymore okay and george started
feeling bad okay
but the night before my cat gooner
spilt milk
onto the xbox but i it wasn't i didn't
see the milk go into the circuitry
it just hit some of the xbox on top i
wiped it down and i played for four
hours on it and it was [ __ ] fine
okay the reason why i blamed i told
looked at george about the milk was
because i didn't want him to feel bad
so on top of that i lie to make people
feel better wow but all afternoon you
were like george you broke my xbox
[Laughter]
and i was following me he was like
i was sweating for
yesterday and then i asked him hey where
are you going he's like george [ __ ]
broke my xbox
so you said it about 80 times i don't
know if that makes anyone feel better
it was sweaty it's how you make the
[ __ ] machine go that's true this is
an engine all right and it runs on
certain kinds of fuels milk and
circuitry
and uh rotors and
what do you anything like rotor i don't
know much about engines radiation
radiation
right and tubes i know there's tubes in
there definitely tubes and so i know how
to keep this [ __ ] machine going and
so you have to throw out lies and
deception
and anger and then kindness and all
kinds of stuff just to get this thing
going wow you're all about stockholm
syndrome it's like attack and then
sweeten them up
it's like let me break you down
emotionally and psychologically but also
let me give you cake afterwards like a
drill sergeant yeah wow that's you're
all yeah that's how wars are overwhelmed
that's why i'm still in this
relationship exactly
like just when he knows i'm about to
like hit my threshold yeah i clean the
house you know what he says to me
but then you know what happens after
this is what he does like he knows i'm
on the verge like he could probably see
the steam coming out of my ears then he
says you know what i'm going to do today
babe i'm going to do some deep cleaning
he knows that that it is going to get
him back out of the doghouse because i'm
going to do some deep i love that
adjective deeply but you know what after
he does a deep cleaning you know what he
does
but for he is the type of guy that
expects
he expects a gold medal for every small
task that he accomplishes so every small
thing like hey look what i did today put
the garbage in the trash can like a
normal human right no but but if he does
that once he did he he expects an
eight-hour bill to tell you why
i'll tell you why because you didn't
know me before i met you
i never took the trash out who took it i
would hire people to do it oh okay
my point is is that these little things
that i do and i brag about it like yeah
i did that right
yeah normal people
do that all the time but to me it's a
new adventure whoa to me it's a new
frontier and an accomplishment for me
like a mount everest times yeah that's
all but
for as much as you know about movies it
really really surprises me that you know
nothing about however our heart bar damn
no spanish directors
so you're very kind of uh
because he talks about what a great
movie buff he is right and he puts us
all down if we don't know like you know
a single movie
but this is the guy who says he's a cell
he's a self-proclaimed movie buff that
he knows so much more than us but he
can't even name one pedro almodovar
movie just one
name one butterfly oh god butterfly
people do you see what i'm saying pedro
almodovar is one of the most
world-renowned directors
you don't need but you're gonna
continuously talk about kurosawa
kurosawa but you know you know nothing
about it i'm gonna look up now
you [ __ ] you really just pissed me
off so bad really that now he's gonna
alert everyone i'm gonna say this i'm
gonna say
top
20 directors
of all time directors of all time if
he's on this list yeah i will watch
every single one of his movies and i'm
going to apologize to you every day for
the next year whoa okay yeah that's our
high stakes top 20 directors of all time
which publication are we going with
general no not in general all right
let's go film comment i bet he's on
there
okay so here we go all right hold on
hold on i am db is that cool no why not
i am going to get like very
american-centered yeah imdb is two
americans
the guardian the guardian is good okay
where is it 40 best directors we'll look
at the top 20. i know but i'll look i'll
name the top 20 for you
obviously
david lynch
martin scorsese
cohen brothers i'm here
steven soderbergh yes terence malik
abbas kiara stami
you don't know him either errol morris
yeah we know errol boris
hayao miyazaki yes david cronenberg oh
my god this is not the right list
terence davis there's no way lucas why
because kurosawa's not even on the top
ten oh oh name one wonkaway movie if
you're oh
what is happening yeah yeah
yeah i'm not listening to this i don't
live in this land if you're such a movie
buff and you're asian make one wrong way
i'm going to say this
right now
kurosawa is not in this list he probably
is he's not he's not on this list what
i'm saying is
this is already the wrong list name one
wang movie and there's no
in the mood for love chung king express
spike jones is on this list and curacao
is not on the side this is not the right
sergio leone there's i mean what the
[ __ ] what kind of list is this this is
not the list i think these people are
all still alive yeah i'm not doing that
list [ __ ] that list just saying i'm just
calling you out guardians i'm doing the
ultimate list of all time imdb that's
what i'm doing
number one stephen spielberg
hmm imdb is american i don't care steven
spielberg is a great [ __ ] director
yeah but you're going to miss out on
martin
alfred hitchcock
stanley kubrick yep right
san francisco coppola okay right
billy wilder okay woody allen
here we go john houston peter jackson
orson welles see now we need to start
milo's foreman
john ford
david lean
inger inger ingmar bergman i don't know
ingrid bergman joel cohen
ridley scott this is already not quite
tarantino none of you no christopher
nolan no bollywood directors okay this
is not george
what i'm saying is stop sitting on your
high horses because you don't know
everything bobby
here we go this is a good one
look he's gonna try to still prove us
wrong i am
i apologize i
you know what
that's
i don't know anything
and i was
you know i was a slept king but now i'm
nothing
because
you know i don't do i don't rip on
gilbert because out of hate
it's out of growth and love thank you
but then it's like you have to tear me
down baby i don't know a la mala barlio
i don't know um
the other guy
you know so let's just go to the
questions then
question yeah
i'm just going to say something go ahead
just in general
i'm going to change my ways
okay
no i'm just saying
and i just want to say i want you to
apologize to me
i need you to apologize for me i'm sorry
bobby for what for
not accepting the the growth
that you were giving me and that's
exactly why i am the sister of kids i'll
tell you why
i'll tell you why because he didn't even
do anything wrong and he apologized and
that makes me the [ __ ] king of all
people this illness i think i'm woke all
right look at me right now man apologize
uh have you saved my number yet
i won't never apologize for that how
long it took me
i'm sorry i'm not worthy of you saving
my number sir [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you all right go give me the
question
don't even do the voice i'm in such a
bad mood now don't even do the [ __ ]
voice i have a visa bobby that's great
hey everybody uh i'm a 27 year old girl
who has a crush on a guy i'm asian and
he is white i'm pretty reluctant to date
white guys in general and i would never
date a guy with yellow fever i'm pretty
sure he's not that but he has a